[音楽]
運ぶってん
さあ
ben
[音楽]
みなさん夏といえばもちろん追加のビーチボール
magumi とかプールに行くと誰しもがこの世界のフィートボールとかで遊んでる
と思うんですけども
あーこの beats ボールを使って取る実機を知ろうと思いますとりあえず
たくさん作る
ませんします
いいます
[音楽]
うはいて具沢山のスイカのビーチボールをズームしました
今回ですねあの前まで普通に使ってたんですけど破けちゃってこうれちゃったんですよ
そこでだそこでコもこれ+いく
のビーチボール2個在庫していくの党務和美私こういう感じで開きましたたってコナン
中にフォローぬ ck を入れます
入るかな矢部さすがに立つ前に8日時間なら左側にこれだと曰くのしかないですね
かぶせます
[音楽]
5声を張ってあっまたなるべくへ仕上げて芝をなくせば結構バレない日が来るんですよ
イヤーパッドに大丈夫なん済み花これはい中継でパック見てる普通の成果のビーチ
ボールに見えるんですけども1個だけ本物のスイカですで多分なんですねちょっと芝が
目立つんですけどパッと見た分バカだったらわかんないんで
これを並べて焼く外に置いといて俺が決定決定って
1個ずつキュッとエッ
入って決定ラストいく受けたら本物のスイカだったっていうのが自分であるというか誰
かにワックもらった成果を食べたいので
ターゲットに足でスイカ割りをしてもらおうと思います
いいいいいい
うーんどんな顔するんでウケがいいというわけでスイカのビーチボールを蹴ったら本物
撥水彼方ドッキリ
やっていこうと思いますでは行くよ
ん
[音楽]
あれ
b
ん
ana
[音楽]
voodoo
びばでー
一般01月
いやもう1本の元するんだこれ
ません
声ん
ええええええ
rar
ber
[音楽]
rejet
voodoo
ちょっとした6分
とって埋まって
dee
きれいすぎんねってぃ腫エビ言われている
努力でビーチボールのせいかと思ったら本物のスイカとキルでしたーー
[音楽]
娘がん